it's the oldest story in the book
liberal policies do a number on Democrat
run cities sewing chaos crime and poop
and crusted streets residents beg for
mercy and then Democrats pivot to
sounding like Republicans Philly's newly
inaugurated mayor promising more cops on
the beat and declaring a public safety
emergency in her her in her first
executive order in
office we're going to make our city safe
for the people who live here who work
here and who come into our city from the
suburbs and from across the country and
from across the world if we don't get
our own house in order before company
comes and if we don't address Public
Safety we won't be ready to receive
anybody in
2026 I am fully committed to ending this
sense of lawlessness and bringing order
back to our city and a sense of
lawfulness sounds like a Republican and
Biden's border crisis causing Democrat
Mayors to sound like GOP border security
Hawks Addison Township police officers
did not know if any of those 40
individuals were carrying weapons they
couldn't be identified and that is a
major problem that's a major security
risk it's a health risk and we're just
not going to tolerate that the solution
for me as the mayor of Edison is not to
pawn it off to another
mayor Jesse if they only watched this
show they could have avoided this mess
why is this always the case should we
have elections year round so they start
acting like adults year round elections
what do you mean by that every month we
have an election so they're constantly
listening to their constituents and
keeping their City safe how about that
Jesse well that would be good for
Ratings it would really be good for
Ratings more hair products for you
that's true that's true I can't get
enough I think what happened was is that
the Trump derangement syndrome combined
with the George Floyd hysteria triggered
all of these anxious Democrats who
already had daddy issues
uh who are already incredibly
insecure uh to become radical racial
revolutionaries and what they wanted to
do is label the
entire Western Civilization as an evil
patriarchy infused with racism and they
had to tear it down and you know instead
of saying no we handed these people a
sledgehammer and for the last three
years have watched them just take strike
after strike at the pillars of our Civic
Society knocking out the prison system
knocking out the criminal justice system
knocking out the education system and
it's not it's actually immoral to
release the same criminal month after
month to pray on the public it's immoral
to teach children about racism instead
of teaching them how to read it's
immoral to let poison flood into the
streets and have everybody die on the
cement and so we stand around watching
it all happen and and if you want to do
something about it if a Democrat wants
to identify as a republican that's the
kind of transitioning that I support
right I was just down in Philly and
Walnut Street the nicest commercial
District all of the flagship shops have
shut down because they can't protect
their merchandise they can't protect
their customers and they can't protect
their employees and Jessica I mean if
you want to have all the great stuff
that liberals love in cities like
Italian leather shops andem and these
ridiculous ly pretentious art galleries
and your little Asian fusion hot
restaurants that no one can understand
what's on the menu That's all going to
leave all of the wealth all of the
commercial activity is just going to
leave and you're just going to wind up
with a gaping wound in the cly of
Brotherly Love oh that is touching it's
true that's the Liberty Bell now is
selling its own
crack Jessica how does it feel to be
pushing such an immoral vision for
America it must make you sick to sick to
your stomach I I'm going to puke in the
sea block actually get ready for it
that's for a different reason
yeah okay um
so the new
mayor acknowledged that there has been a
drop in the murder and property crime
and property most people don't get
murdered Jessica but a lot of people get
mug they certainly aren telling you
about it um but she doesn't
sound like anything but a regular
Democrat you're no it's true she's not
saying and she doesn't sound like a
republican she's not saying bring back
stop and frisk or three strikes in your
out or get all the undocumented people
out of America she's
talking she's she just got elected she
has a wild to Coast on this one she's
speaking in common sense terms and I was
struck by the fact that this is probably
what people in Chicago would have heard
if Paul valis had won that election
instead of Brandon Johnson right they
would have gotten arousing opening day
speech about cutting down on crime and
it does again have to be noted that it
is moving in the right direction um but
I think it's great I think it's a great
example and it's important that it is a
Democrat talking that way mayor Adams
talks that way here in New York he does
and I I think you will continue to see
more of it on the order front Biden just
requested $ 13.6 billion which Mike
Johnson he was on in the last hour with
Jake Tapper he says he's not going to
improve it even though it means 1300 new
border patrol agents 375 new judges
1,600 Asylum officers to expedite
screenings Republicans need to play ball
if they're getting what they want what's
the point if he's going to let them in
anyway not the point here's the problem
if Biden gets more money and every
answer is every problem is solved with
the money is an answer all he's going to
do is put more border patrol and let
more people in 302,000 people in the
month of December that's outrageous the
last month that Trump was in office it
was 70,000 look I want to talk about
this woman I want to give her the
benefit of the doubt am I stupid maybe
am I a sucker maybe but at the same time
she said things that made sense to me
she said that what she wanted to do was
put more cops on the street okay she
said she wanted to have job opportunity
programs for kids after school cuz we
all know that's when they get into
trouble she wants to have an Economic
Opportunity program so people can better
the homes in their neighborhoods she
said you know and she impressed me as a
as a black woman who seems to care about
her community all right it is the black
community and the brown community that
are the victims of crime and it's not
just the color of her skin I just
believe what she's saying cuz we know
from mayor Adams does make it a damn bit
of difference that he was a cop he
hasn't done a damn thing Brandon Johnson
doesn't make a damn bit of difference
that he's from the minority Community I
just want to believe that she's going to
do something for her community and I'm
impressed by her now the the the the guy
who's a mayor who won't let 40 people
into that city of New Jersey um because
there a security risk a health risk he
says that um he doesn't want to send
them to another town he wants to send
them to the Border but the problem is if
he sends him to the Border they're not
going to send him back they're going to
let him into the country so two things
there I like this woman I want to give
her the benefit of the doubt and the
mayor I don't know I think he's just
talking politics Dana you know I know
this is going to tick you off because it
ticks me off as well go back three four
years to all those interrupted brunches
all those BLM Marchers uh uh all these
people talking about how bad the system
is so many eggs benedict ruined yeah
exactly oh my God don't get me started
on the on the Belgian waffle but where
are like where are they they it's almost
like they need to be like taken to an
auditorium and lectured because this is
what happens by someone like her yeah
and I I would I think that one of the
things that's impressive about her is
she has a strong
voice just like actual strong voice so
she should use the bully pulpit every
single day and just be out there she
could join up with somebody like the
mayor in Dallas because black guy who's
in Dallas who's trying to do the right
thing he ultimately decided to change
parties but who cares these are people
who care about their communities another
problem she has is the fact that Larry
ker is still the prosecutor you can do
all of these things you could bring more
police there but if they're not going to
prosecute the crimes and the cops know
that they're just going to that their
jobs don't mean anything then you're not
going to be able to get anywhere and I
don't she didn't mention any of that so
I think the jury is still out the jury
is still out excellent analogy well done
well done okay we're going to move on to
something exciting hi everyone I'm Brian
kilme I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now